let's go next to our caller from the
8:01 area code who's calling today from
8:01 welcome hey David thanks for having
me
I just want to ask you what it's tested
someone tolerates the religion or the
religious practices of their parents and
how should you approach a conversation
with your parents if you feel like there
are certain lines being crossed okay so
I'm having a little bit of trouble
understanding exactly what you're saying
the first part was to what extent should
you respect the religious views of your
parents or tolerate I think was the word
you used yep tolerate well I I would
want to know what you mean if or if
you're asking do you need to be the same
religion as your parents or have the
same views I think the answer is clearly
no if you're talking about do you
should you be respectful of your parents
views in order to maintain a friendly
relationship then that's sort of up to
you and what your priorities are right
yeah no that makes sense so what was the
other part of a question yeah so if
there are certain practices that your
parents engage in whether it's prayer or
whether it's like imposing certain
beliefs yeah in this case it's speaking
specifically like Christianity how
should you approach the conversation
with them that their belief in their
facts is sort of make you uncomfortable
or make you uneasy what would be the
point what would be your goal in the
conversation let's start there yeah I
guess just to be on the same page with
them but I want them to you want them to
stop the prayer and so in some settings
right so I'll give you an example my
thoughts and I had a I get together with
a bunch of different people from my
family and from their family and at a
certain point my parents decided they
were going to pray and invite everyone
to do like a group prayer and I sort of
asked him not to engage in that but they
sort of did it anyways and it just
seemed like any conversation I had with
them about whether or not that prayer
was gonna happen
wasn't conducted right and I think I've
had to spend approaching it the wrong
way but I wanted to get your advice I
mean
listen you know I've actually I know
friends who have experienced that
situation I have some friends who the
parents so it's a couple the parents of
one of the people are completely
non-religious the parents of the other
person in the couple are very religious
and often want when everybody gets
together they want to do 30 minutes of
Bible study and stuff like that the way
that it was handled there and I can't
think of any other way to do it quite
frankly is the the child of the
religious parents pulled them aside and
said listen my spouse's family is not
religious we want to have a nice time
people get uncomfortable when you want
to do 30 minutes of Bible study and it
would be better for everybody if we skip
that and they they did take offense but
they accepted it and there's no more
Bible study when everybody gets together
but the thing is it that that's how one
set of people reacted you know your
parents may react in a different way so
I don't know that there's one right
answer here katja know that make sense
okay I don't envy the position that
you're in
yeah all right appreciate the phone call
great to hear from you let's take a
quick break if you were holding
don't hang up because we are going to go
right back to the phones it's gonna feel
like it's mere seconds stay with me